TODD: FOX NEWS CAMERAS CATCH
GROUPS OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
CROSSING THE BORDER NOT ONLY
FROM THE NORTHERN TRIANGLE.
>> GHANA, YOU’RE FROM GHANA,
BRAZIL, YOU ARE FROM BRAZIL, YOU
ARE FROM HAITI.
JILLIAN: TOMI LAHREN IS HERE TO
REACT, 1 MILLION BORDER ARRESTS
THIS YEAR AND YOU HAVE HEARD
THOSE PEOPLE SAY THEY ARE FROM
GHANA, BRAZIL, HAITI, NOT JUST
PEOPLE COMING FROM THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE OR MEXICO, FEEL LIKE
SOMETHING HAS CHANGED IT.
WHAT IS IT THAT HAS CHANGED?
>> FOR SIMPLE WHAT CHANGED, THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
WHEN YOU WELL, MILLION PLUS
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS INTO THIS
COUNTRY IT IS BECOMING A CHOICE
AND AN OBVIOUS CHOICE BY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION THAT AS YOU
SEE THE MESSAGE HAS BEEN SENT
AROUND THE WORLD WE ARE A FREE
FOR ALL, WE HAVE OPEN BORDERS,
COME ONE, COME OFF AND IT IS
IRONIC WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT UP
AT THE WHITE HOUSE AND THE
GOVERNMENT AND LARGE, FACEBOOK
POSTS ABOUT COVID TYRANNY ARE
PROBLEMATIC BUT WELCOMING
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS LEGALLY
UNTESTED THAT DOESN’T SEEM TO BE
A PROBLEM FOR THIS
ADMINISTRATION SO YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE THEY PRIORITIZE
THE HEALTH OF AMERICANS AND
PEOPLE COMING IN BECAUSE AT THIS
POINT IT IS BEYOND A CRISIS, IT
IS ABSOLUTELY A CHOICE.
>> THEY ARE BASHING BEN AND
JERRY’S FOR REFUSING TO SELL ICE
CREAM IN THE WEST BANK AND EAST
JERUSALEM CALLING IT PALESTINIAN
TERRITORY.
WOKE MAKES YOU BROKE, ISN’T THIS
GOING TO HURT SALES FOR THOSE
WHO PRACTICE JUDAISM IN THE US?
>> YOU WOULD THINK SO BUT I HAVE
LONG SINCE ABANDONED HOPE THAT
LEFTIST COMPANIES WOULD STAND UP
FOR MY MORAL VALUES AND MY MORAL
COMPASS.
I WISH WE COULD RETURN TO THE
DAYS COMPANY SOLD PRODUCTS
INSTEAD OF VIRTUE SIGNALS WHERE
EVERYTHING WASN’T A POLITICAL
STATEMENT, SPORTS ABOUT PLAYING
BALL, NOT POLITICS, WE ENTERED
THE POINT WERE WOKEISM HAS
SIGNIFICANT I DON’T BELIEVE IN
CAPITAL CULTURE THE TIME TO LOOK
AT THESE COMPANIES AND SAY WHAT
ARE YOU STANDING FOR?
I AM LESS WORRIED WHAT BEN AND
JERRY’S CHOOSE TO DO, POSSIBLE
ANTI-SEMITIC CHOICES THEY CHOOSE
TO MAKE, FAR MORE CONCERNED WITH
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS MAKING OF
THOSE STATEMENTS ON A DAILY
BASIS BECAUSE THEIR OWN PARTY IS
NOT HOLDING THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
BEN AND JERRY’S BAD MOVE BUT I’M
MORE CONCERNED ABOUT OUR ELECTED
LEADERS WHO ARE DOING WORSE.
>> THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
LOOKING AT PEOPLE’S SOCIAL MEDIA
POSTS BUT THE PENTAGON IS ALSO
REPORTEDLY WORKING WITH AN
EXTREMISM ANALYSIS COMPANY
SEARCHING SERVICEMEMBERS, SOCIAL
MEDIA PAGES TO SEE IF THERE’S
ANYTHING THEY DEEM AS EXTREMIST
CONTENTS BUT SKIPPING SLOGANS
LIKE ANTI-POLICE SLOGANS.
APPARENTLY THAT IS A SIGN AND
FORMER SPACE FORCE COMMAND,
SPACE FORCE COMMANDER ON THE
PENTAGON.
HERE’S WHAT HE HAD TO SAY.
>> VERY LITTLE SURPRISES ME
ANYMORE AS I CONTINUE TO
CONSIDER JUST HOW FOCUSED THE
DEFENSE DEPARTMENT IS ON ROOTING
OUT WHITE EXTREMISM AND WHITE
SUPREMACY.
I AM NOT SURE EXACTLY HOW IT IS
YOU ARE ABLE TO TELL FROM SEARCH
TERMS THAT MUCH ABOUT THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE SERVING IN
UNIFORM.
>> PEOPLE SAY SCHOOL, HOLLYWOOD
HAVE AWOKE AND NOW IT IS
AFFECTING THE MILITARY AS WELL.
>> IT ABSOLUTELY HAS BECOME A
SOCIAL EXPERIMENT IN A LOT OF
WAYS, CRITICAL RACE THEORY IN
ALMOST EVERY CORNER OF AMERICAN
SOCIETY BUT IT DOES SEEM THEIR
CONCERN, ROOTING OUT ANYTHING
THEY DEEM WHITE SUPREMACY BUT
WHAT THEY ARE REALLY MEANING IS
FIGURE OUT WHO IN A GROUP,
SOMETHING OCCURRING FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS AND I REMIND
FOLKS YOU WANT TO LOOK AT
EXTREMIST IDEOLOGY LOOK NO
FURTHER THAN THE ORGANIZATION
THAT IS BLM THAT HAS SUPPORT FOR
FIDEL CASTRO, DEFUNDING THE
POLICE, DEMONIZING POLICE,
TERRORIZING OUR CITIES, LOOK NO
FURTHER THAN BLM IF YOU WANT TO
LOOK AT EXTREMIST IDEOLOGY AND
WHAT IS TRULY HARMING OUR
COUNTRY.
>> THE MILITARY HAS ONE JOB TO
PROTECT AMERICA.
I DON’T SEE HOW THESE
DISTRACTIONS HELP THAT MISSION.
CHECK OUT TOMI LAHREN’S SHOW NO
INTERRUPTION, DON’T HAVE THE
PICTURE OF YOU WITH THE FINGER
ANYMORE, JUST A STRAIGHT ON